how many things would you attempt
if you knew you could not fail
the reason why worry kills more people
than work
is that more people worry than work
the afternoon knows what the morning
never suspected
love is an irresistible desire to be
irresistibly desired
half the world is composed of people who
have something to say and can't
and the other half who have nothing to
say
and keep on saying it
a bank is a place where they lend you an
umbrella in fair weather
and ask for it back when it begins to
rain
education is the ability to listen to
almost anything without losing your
temper or your self-confidence
a mother takes 20 years to make a man
out of her boy
and another woman makes a fool of him in
20 minutes
there is one thing more exasperating
than a wife who can cook and won't
and that's a wife who can't cook and
will
if we couldn't laugh
we would all go insane
freedom lies in being bold
the best way out
is always through
happiness makes up in height for what it
lacks in length
home is the place where when you have to
go there
they have to take you in
don't ever take a fence down
until you know why it was put up
we love the things we love for what they
are
never be bullied into silence
never allow yourself to be made a victim
except no one's definition of your life
define yourself
a diplomat is a man who always remembers
a woman's birthday
but never remembers her age
to be a poet is a condition
not a profession
there are two kinds of teachers
the kind that fill you with so much
quail shot that you can't move
and the kind that gives you a little
prod behind
and you jump to the skies
poetry is when an emotion has found its
thought and the thought has found words
how many things have to happen to you
before something occurs to you
we dance round in a ring and suppose
but the secret sits in the middle and
knows
something we were withholding made us
weak
until we found it was ourselves
a jury consists of 12 persons chosen to
decide who has the better lawyer
the world is full of willing people
some willing to work
the rest willing to let them
thinking is not to agree or disagree
that's voting
the brain is a wonderful organ
it starts working the moment you get up
in the morning and does not stop until
you get into the office
unless you are educated in metaphor
you are not safe to be let loose in the
world
by faithfully working 12 hours a day
you may eventually get to be boss and
work 14 hours a day
families break up when they get hints
you don't intend
and miss hints that you do
a liberal is a man too broad-minded to
take his own side in a quarrel
you are always believing ahead of your
evidence
the most creative thing in us
is to believe in a thing
a person will sometimes devote all of
his life to the development of one part
of his body
the wishbone
a civilized society is one which
tolerates eccentricity to the point of
doubtful sanity
anything more than the truth
would be too much
good fences
make good neighbors
you've got to love what's lovable
and hate what's hate-able
it takes brains to see the difference
what we live by we die by
most of the change we think we see in
life
is due to truths being in and out of
favor
the best things and best people
rise out of their separateness
education doesn't change life much
it just lifts trouble to a higher plane
of regard
a poem begins as a lump in the throat
a sense of wrong
a homesickness
a love sickness
being the boss anywhere is lonely
being a female boss in a world of mostly
men is especially so
for dear me
why abandon a belief merely because it
ceases to be true
what is done is done for the love of it
or not really done at all
the worst disease which can afflict
executives in their work is not
as popularly supposed alcoholism
it's egotism
nobody has ever meant to remember or
invent what he did with every cent
our very life depends on everything
recurring till we answer from within
life must be kept up at a great rate in
order to absorb any considerable amount
of learning
a poem begins in daylight
and ends in wisdom
don't tell anyone that you're lonely
because once again you will convince
yourself of this
no tears in the writer
no tears in the reader
no surprise in the writer
no surprise in the reader
talking is a hydrant in the yard
and writing is a faucet upstairs in the
house
opening the first takes all the pressure
off the second
poetry is what gets lost in translation
avoid people who see your shortcomings
and justify or even approve of them
such people are either flatterers or
cowards or simply fools
do not expect help from them
in any trouble or misfortune
like a piece of ice on a hot stove
the poem must ride on its own melting
never marry a woman who has already had
many men
it is likely that she will use her
experience to harm you
to be social
is to be forgiving
there never was any heart truly great
and generous
that was not all so tender and
compassionate
the chief reason for going to school is
to get the impression fixed for life
that there is a book side for everything
an idea is a feat of association
and the height of it
is a good metaphor
you